[Musique]
bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur mes chers français et
mes chers français le doit d'abord je
voudrais m'excuser auprès des
téléspectateurs car sans posséder la
télévision moi même j'imagine qu'il doit
y avoir des sujets des missions plus
intéressant que d'entendre le secrétaire
d'état aux finances vous parler des
impôts
il est toujours difficile de parler de
soi et pourtant il faut le faire pour
vous dire qui est ce candidat à la
présidence de la république que je suis
je vais vous parler pour la france
rayonne
elle doit offrir un visage humain
libérale mondialiste et moderne je suis
né le 2 février 1926
j'ai 48 ans le bon choix est dicté par
le bon sens voudrait ajouter que je suis
mariée que nous avons quatre enfants
deux filles et deux fils je suis le
candidat de l'espoir et c'est pourquoi
je vous regarde ce soir et c'est
pourquoi aussi vous ne regardez parce
que je suis celui qui est construit les
fondations je voudrais regarder la
france au fond des yeux mais je voudrais
aussi atteindre son coeur ce qui n'en
compte pas construit les fondations ne
peuvent construire qu'une maison de
papier parcouru par les courants d'air
des fausses promesses et des déceptions
les murs de ma maison seront des murs de
pierre d'abord je vous dire quelque
chose je trouve toujours choquant et
blessant de s'arroger le monopole du
coeur d'abord ne pas conduire un peuple
les yeux bandés le départ monsieur
mitterrand monopole du coeur vous n'avez
pas en effet vous gérez le ministère de
la parole ceci depuis 1965 où depuis
1974 moi je gérais la france adieu donc
1974 et salut à toi
1975 pour la politique française
le changement sans le risque moi je
souhaite que ma campagne choix de la
lure la plus libre pochic pour les
spécialistes le président pratique un
ski un peu trop raide on lui reproche un
manque de souplesse une trop grande
recherche de vitesse pure c'est
peut-être une question de tempérament ne
se corrige pas acquise c'est quelque
chose qui tenait aussi pas me ferait de
vous le dire à mon caractère et à l'idée
que j'ai de ma fonction et qui est qu'
il faut laisser les choses basse mourir
de leur propre poison
je n'ai pas la prétention et je n'ai
même pas le désir de gagner seul ou de
gouverner seul avant de vous quitter je
vous souhaite bonne chance
madame mademoiselle monsieur je compte
sur vous pour que le jour venu vous
puissiez compter sur moi au revoir
[Musique]